you
all right let's get rolling here here we
go team white let's try d4 again okay
let's go with c4 Queens gambit declined
or accepted its accepted let's make sure
I get that pawn back I don't think I
need to grab them right away
get them bishop bishop here I could play
this
alright let's scoop them up so what do
we have well what might we have is a 6 B
5 or that lets get castled I might want
to okay yeah we're gonna have this hmm
what's the move here Queenie - oh no I'm
yeah I'm gonna go with the Queen - E -
so my bishop could get kicked around B 5
Bishop here you know he kicked around
some more I need to be prepared - okay
we're not going down that road I was
going to say I need be prepared to get
in this essential expansion so I think I
should weaken this structure let's throw
this in if push then I get the C 4
square for my knight I want to be
cautious of this square if B 4 I pretty
much don't want to touch this pawn
because this night I'll have a
fast-track to that square okay so I
don't think I need to grab and right
just yet I think my knight is going to
be the one who's better suited to do
just that and let's see Knight here
rook here I'm gonna get my rook here
behind that pond
I don't think I need to do anything just
yet he's going nowhere he's attacked
twice defended zero and okay so there's
pressure on this square now all right I
see that he's indirectly defended
however and got some tricky stuff on h7
we're even on time
there's Knight to c5 keep in mind I have
this isolated pawns so these are the
squares I'm looking to be jumping into
what do I do um what do i do my bishop I
definitely play here it comes with tempo
if Bishop lock maybe I come here and be
annoying
place the knight in a pin I gotta be on
the lookout for some tricks on the h7
square if this Knight is no long around
on f7 there's some ideas for maybe
taking on this square in Knight g5 in
some lines this is a very active move
yeah a very active move hmm that move
scares me like I can't do this move or
maybe I can yeah here takes takes rook
takes Bishop I'd have to invest two
minor pieces in a row to get a queen
this I didn't really consider I should
have though all right let's back up I
think I could take this pawn yeah why am
I not taking that pawn maybe I could do
that no I want to hang on to that pawn
this is a very active move a very
annoying move placing it in my position
on my side of the board I don't like
that and neither should you
you should not like these moves either
they're annoying
look at how inconvenient it is another
thing is if I played Bishop d2 black
didn't have to react to the threat on
the rook that could have followed up
with Knight takes d4 Knight takes rook
takes so I needed some more support for
this still that you can't take on this
square because at the end there's Bishop
takes here so oh if I do this I'm
dropping my knight so let's not I could
win this pawn what am I missing
Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes is
something like this being lined up that
Bill Gates square that Bill Gates square
what about rook c1 hmm
why hang on for a second why not take
upon that's a big question I don't do I
have a good reason not to take that pun
and I might end up losing him he's kind
of I mean I don't like him here or is
another I'm gonna take the pun i I don't
see a reason not to take the pawn so
let's take him
is he a freebie it doesn't feel like I'm
up a full pond to be honest it feels
like there's I'm a little bit off
balance in some way I still need a
flight square but okay so too does black
know okay yeah we're looking for these
sneak sneak attacks I'm gonna lose my
darks for a bishop but I was I was fine
with that I'm gonna have to be fine with
that
okay I think if I take here I'm just
helping him out so let's go here let's
make sure I don't get made it on each to
one day now if Knight takes here do I
take with my queen or my pawn you know
what I'm gonna have to take with my pawn
my queen is uh so maybe that was a
reason to first take on this square okay
my dark squares are clearly weak is rook
here gonna be a pain I'm gonna place
this guy in a pin and buy this guy I
mean the night isn't that uncomfortable
it's gotta be uncomfortable it's gotta
be uncomfortable
it's just got to okay there's Bishop g3
and that's super inconvenient what about
push here Bishop f4 what about simply
rook here up to c2 is my queen gonna get
deflected from defense of the night I
hope not
playing hope chess all of a sudden okay
they I have a flight Square at least so
with this trade off even though I'm down
my dark square Bishop to Knights versus
Knight ambition they still have to solve
um maybe back rank issues this is close
to being super inconvenient
yeah okay I'm usually a fan of Queen
trades I'm gonna go for it let's throw
another piece on that night am I not
winning material I think this is a one
game now let me just double-check not in
the chess sense double-check but Knight
b6 and take care that should do the
trick just kicking away that's rook rook
b8 rook takes Knight yeah this is this
is netting material that got to be too
much as Queen c7 move it had a close eye
on h2 but yeah this is big trouble less
than a minute but I don't think there's
going to be any issue timewise still
have to remain focused let's see I don't
want to get into the mindset of oh the
time is just going to well not the time
by all the position is gonna collapse I
want to make sure I still follow through
and make good moves again I believe that
I'm just winning material okay I saw
that there was this move like if rook
takes you take here first and only then
recapture but the idea here is that I
could actually take because my Knights
their defense e2 and let's just take
here and you cannot avoid the rook
exchange I could always play there so
let's make sure my King gets off a dark
square King position it's not dropping
my knight 41 seconds okay he's gonna
play this one out and well okay I have
enough puns I don't want to get into a
position where it's okay let's let's go
after he has to go back now otherwise I
get him I don't want to get into a
position where I have two knights and
there's no pawns on the board so I'm
gonna play my pawn here and with this
will now come a great wall right here
all four of these squares are covered if
pawn push I could do this yeah let's do
this right now actually I don't want to
move him I'm gonna keep these guys
sitting just to keep the King boxed out
LightSquared grip eventually I'm going
to reposition this guy somewhere so he
does something more let's get King
position where it is my knight belong
right here and do some weaknesses knight
here have him move and then come back
here to d5 and strike at this point or
that okay so he's defending with the
Bishop 27 seconds okay I have another
path though oh another thing I don't I
don't this is a better position for the
knight he's he's watching over this this
is good enough
is he gonna flinch that Bishop this
isn't the most effective technique I
must say eventually he's gonna have to
do this well then he's dropping that
pawn now I'll push now that I have a
much better King position now my King
and pawn stop him I guess you have to do
this eventually now he's he's in a tough
spot now I can drop back I'm on this
point I just want to kick the King back
check checking moves here d6 or a 5 less
than 10 for black let's go here there
should be some night mate right around
the corner yeah there's some mate
there's definitely gonna be some mate
soon and oh my goodness for a second I
thought I lost on time that scared the
life out of me oh my goodness my heart
definitely skipped a beat when that
popped up right there I thought it was a
sign that my clock dropped right there
okay they resigned right there with 1.8
seconds I really did I I got a little
scared right there okay yeah I could
have done anything I was just trying to
calculate some little mate there as a
finish but okay let's go back here and
I'll look from your perspective game
history okay from your perspective here
and that's about as well what do we have
Queens gambit accepted I have with that
now the central majority which never
really got working but
if you went for this structure if black
goes in this direction with c4 I back up
as soon as that's that's the big
transition in this position that's the
potential that this position can have
structure wise with c4
as soon as c4 is in it's officially a
three versus two majority on the
queenside
and now I have a free two versus one
majority so that's that's going to be my
play that's going to be my plan as a
follow-up but we don't get there because
there's immediate capture and now black
is simply playing against this d4 pawn
what exactly went wrong bishop here I
don't see anything wrong with that I
mean is we're starting to get into maybe
move order nuances with Bishop to b7
with Knight to d7 I'm not sure I'm not
sure what's best I mean is there a
reason to keep some support on this
there might be some sacrifices right
around the corner like 95 here maybe
there's a way a reason in other words to
keep him at least for the moment still
watching over this my only other square
that I might want to go to with the as
black I wonder if there's also d6 it's a
tough call okay but Knight Bishop to e7
I didn't point it out I don't think
during the game but a natural move here
is Knight c3 but I didn't want to commit
my knight just yet until you see I was
already at this point anticipating b5
it's a common move I've seen it before
so I have some experience with that and
I played Queen e2 it's developing its
allowing rook to d1 and I didn't want to
commit my Knight to c3 because I wanted
to have this possibility of of going to
d2 and then c4 like I'm seeing after b5
in this exchange I get to play this with
my knight still on its home square if b4
in this position which I believe is the
other move to really be considering
then it's not coming with tempo I'm not
having to well I can have a central
square to go to but I wanted to have
this idea where after a four if you are
not capturing and instead grabbing a
little bit of space watching over c3 I
have a quick track to the c-4 square and
maybe even one day there could be this
clamping down move with a five and then
there's a pivot square on b6 for my
knight so I guess I was just rattling
off a bunch of stuff right there I guess
in short I want to make sure that when
it comes time for this position when my
queen is I want to play Queen e2 instead
of Knight to c3 I want to see how black
reacts when I strike at it with a four
so b5 comes a four is happening so he's
still in his home square I want to be
able to play a four with my knight still
in his home squares what I'm getting at
I guess that's the shortest summary
maybe they're shorter but okay
I didn't reference that during the game
but it was a thought that was running
through my mind
I didn't voice it aloud is what I meant
okay but in case he captured so now I
could freely come to that natural square
there's no need to grab with the rook
it's the knight who should be getting
developed this is the square he has in
mind the other night has the e5 square
castles here hmm this Knight is maybe I
wonder if this Knight move was where
there's some issues you see if the
knight is on D 7 and they're connected
when my Knight captures here he'll be
conveniently watching over c5 & b6 maybe
this there's some adjustment with the
Queen Knights deployment maybe he's
better on d7 instead of c6 I mean as it
turned out in the game I mean you're
putting pressure on my pawn but well
Hinton this is much deeper but he's he's
the one who ended up having some issues
he's he's a loose piece he's a loose
piece I maybe he's a bit more secure on
d7 maybe that's another way to look at
it so Knight takes rook here I was kind
of happy with this move Bishop f4 but
you're getting super active with your
rook
Bishop back Queen c7 yeah maybe you have
to be super delicate with the Queen
position this is tough for me and you
know the other thing is that when you
make this capture maybe maybe this is
really the wrong choice I wonder because
he is hit he's getting he's getting
absolutely hammered right I mean it's
it's already going to be difficult
enough from the pressure along this
diagonal but now now you have to contend
with eventually they directly or
indirectly pressure with by the rook on
a1 so he's going to be tough to defend I
mean in the game he ended up being lost
but it's tough for me to say I don't I
don't have a different advance or a way
to really be certain how you can improve
thinking I'm thinking the nighties may
be better on d7 it's a tough call for me
to be honest or maybe even maybe even
Knight to b5 come to think of it and I
look to b8 how about this just playing
against playing against my isolated pawn
like b4 to d5 just throwing some
different ideas out there this got to be
quite problematic and I guess okay
you're getting my bishop but I guess you
have your own problems as well with this
this file I was constantly on the
lookout for moves like rook to e8 but
you never had control over that square
otherwise I could be in some trouble
with my knight here I don't I don't know
I think I think it's just LA it's well
not lost but it's certainly very
difficult for you you pick up my bishop
again but now I have flight square and
you have to devote some time to creating
flight square for your own and the
position has already opened up it's
difficult to devote a strictly defensive
move in the form of flight square when
the position is so opened and I think
we're beyond saving at this point maybe
even already a couple moves back yeah
the night ended up being lost and it's
just game over I think already here
he's gone and then yeah I think it I
think it's maybe important that I this
last detail that I do have this resource
to take and defend c2 rook takes rook
has met with Knight check first
then you recapture I think white would
still maybe be the better side because
of this past bond but it's certainly not
as clear of course not up the minor
piece but as it played out I'm just up a
piece and just make sure I convert it
push my upon keeping this position just
a small pattern recognition having the
Nitin pond on the same color square they
are coordinated very well and just
moving forward like so scared me right
there at the end with the resigning I
thought it was my time that fell okay
good game structural defect I have to
maybe in some lines simply be content
with losing my c4 pond the c-4 pond is
weak because the square it sits on as we